joué-lès-tours un peu plus de 35000
habitants et un budget de fonctionnement
qui avoisine les 40 2 millions d'euros
chaque année la ville reçoit de l'état
un peu plus de 9 millions d'euros 1
million au titre de la dotation de
solidarité urbaine et 8,2 millions
d'euros pour la dotation globale de
fonctionnement
et c'est justement cette dotation
globale de fonctionnement qui pose
problème au maire celle ci ne doit en
effet augmenté que de 2% en 2009 or la
tva que les communes pouvaient
auparavant récupérer sur leur
investissement sera désormais incluses
dans cette enveloppe pour philippe le
breton le compte n'y est pas simplement
de 2% cette année en le taux d'évolution
de l'inflation prévue pour 2009 le dut
ont la tête dans ce qui devait augmenter
de 2% est ce dû il participe accès 2%
dont louise qui va rester dans les 9 %
en 2008 joué-lès-tours a récupéré près
de 1,5 million d'euros de tva autant
d'argent perdu selon le maire mais il ya
aussi la taxe professionnelle rétrocéder
chaque année par l'agglomération
après avoir été plafonnées celle ci doit
être réformé l'élu est inquiet mais
surtout s'impatiente alors pour la
première fois il ne sera pas voté le
budget en temps et en heure d'habitude
le vote se fait en décembre et en
descente je considère que nous n'aurons
pas assez d'éléments pour avoir un
budget bien construit un budget sincère
et donc j'ai demandé à ma majorité de
retarder le vote du budget qui se fera
peut être fin janvier peut-être à la
mi-février baisse des dotations
étatiques et suppression de la dotation
de solidarité urbaine à tour saint
pierre et amboise l'état demande aux
collectivités locales de faire des
économies d'autant plus qu'à la
différence des finances nationales les
collectivités ne peuvent pas voter un
budget en déficit les élus de gauche
sont donc nombreux à se plaindre
communes conseils généraux et régionaux
tous dénoncent d'être mise à la diète et
de voir parallèlement leurs charges
augmenter au département d'indre et
loire le plafonnement de la tva aurait
représenté en 2008
2 9 millions d'euros de manque à gagner
à la région on développe également le
même discours pour le budget 2009 nous
considérons pas ce que chez la réalité
des chiffres que 35 millions de charges
nouvelles viendront non compensés dans
ce budget mais pour le gouvernement le
compte y est les élus de droite relais
cette position et relève des évolutions
qui doivent être nécessairement prises
en compte dans les finances publiques
c'est un grand mensonge c'est de la
politique politicienne moins de moyens
dans l'éducation nationale c'est moins
de moyens parce qu'il ya moins d'élèves
tout simplement qu'aujourd'hui il y à un
recentrage et une réorganisation il faut
arrêter de gaspiller l'argent public et
redonner cet argent là où il est
productif c'est à dire dans les
entreprises en diminuant les
prélèvements la réforme des finances
publiques l'état compte bien l'appliquer
également aux collectivités
territoriales celle ci pointe du doigt
des conséquences sur les investissements
d'autant plus qu'elles sont de plus en
plus nombreuses à subir les conséquences
de la crise financière
problème de crédit elles ont du mal à
emprunter tout comme les entreprises une
des solutions pourrait être
l'augmentation des impôts locaux mais
ils sont aussi nombreux comme philippe
le breton a refusé cette solution